this is iphone 10. it is the biggest
leap forward since the original iphone
in 2017 apple revolutionized the iphone
with their new iphone 10 packing an
edge-to-edge display in their brand new
face id system which to this day works
incredibly well with the only compromise
being of course the notch which still
exists on the new iphone 13 lineup but
thankfully over the past year we've been
getting some very convincing leaks and
rumors from various sources like the
reliable ming chi kuo the elec and even
the legendary mark german who are all
pointing to the notch days finally being
over with apple's upcoming iphone 14 pro
which will feature a hole punch camera
cutout design and then just a couple of
days ago dylan dkt on twitter came out
and confirmed that apple will not only
be switching to a hole punch design for
the iphone 14 pro but they're also gonna
make it pill shaped yes shaped like a
pail as you can see in this render by
ben geskin on twitter compared to a
regular hole punch design kind of like
in this image from nine tech 11 where
you have the hole punch right here and
the pill shaped cutout right over there
and after doing a bunch of research i'm
finally convinced that the iphone 14 pro
will in fact come with a pill shaped
camera cutout so what i'm going to do in
this video is explain exactly how apple
is going to pull this off while keeping
face id fully functional and then at the
end i'm going gonna reveal some custom
renders of the iphone 14 pro that i had
made by a 3d artist based on all of my
research but before we get into that i
want to ask you guys to go ahead and
click the subscribe button if you're
interested in videos like these to help
us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers now in terms of the pill
shaped cutout story it all begins with a
video i made four months back before
apple even revealed the iphone 13 lineup
and this was based on a major leak from
shrimp apple pro on twitter so let's
jump right into that way back in the
summer of last year shrimp apple pro
showed us this exclusive iphone 14 pro
display panel from one of apple's
suppliers and as you can see it looks
crazy because you have a pill-shaped
cutout right here and another bigger
cutout right next to it and i think
because of that a lot of people just
wrote it off and completely ignored it
but way back then he said that it was
meant for the iphone 14 with a punch
hole and he said there's a 70 to 80
percent chance that apple would use this
design and then later on in september he
gave us another update saying that the
2022 iphone would likely have this
design mentioning that the camera is on
the right so you can see that little
cutout right there that's for the selfie
camera and then the face id system would
be on the left so that bigger cutout
would house some of the face id sensors
along with some sensors going under here
as well and i do want to remind you guys
that the only reason this is possible is
because with the iphone 13 apple took
the speaker cutout with the built-in
microphone and everything and they put
it up to the top of the frame so it's
essentially going to sit above the
display panel right there and that is
the reason why apple is able to
basically free up this portion this gap
in between the camera and the sensors
and the top of the iphone and now going
back to shrimp apple pros leak he says
that apple is doing it for both the 6.1
inch iphone pro and the 6.7 inch iphone
pro max which makes total sense and this
is actually based on ross young's
excellent excellent display leaks
because ross young has a 100 percent
accuracy rating with displays so he's
very very good now check out this chart
ross young believes that there's going
to be four different iphone models next
year there's going to be the regular 6.1
inch iphone 14 but then there's going to
be an iphone 14 max so it's going to get
the larger display but it's not going to
get all of the extra features and then
of course you got the iphone 14 pro and
the 14 pro max with no mini size at all
but if we take a closer look at this
chart we can see some very interesting
details what ross is basically
confirming is that both the regular
iphone 14 and 14 max models will still
get the regular face id with the current
iphone 13 notch however both of the pro
models the pro and the pro max are going
to be getting the new under display face
id system with the cutout and if we go
back to dylan dkt's tweet just a couple
of days ago he said that the face id
hardware will be placed underneath the
display basically exactly what ross
young said so if we go to shrimp apple
pro's leak it looks like this extra
cutout on the side is actually going to
be unnecessary so that leaves us with a
perfectly centered pill shaped cutout
and with that said the big question we
have to answer is how exactly is apple
gonna put the face id hardware under the
display so let's go ahead and explain
how that is going to work by looking at
the original iphone 10s face id system
as you can see in this image of the
entire truedepth sensor array for face
id we of course have the infrared camera
then the proximity sensor the flood
illuminator the ambient light sensor the
speaker the microphone the camera and
the dot projector so first of all we
know that the speaker and microphone are
already out of the notch they're all the
way up to the top of the display on the
iphone 13 but we still have those other
facility sensors that we have to put
underneath the display and before we get
into it the most important thing to
understand about face id is that it
works using an infrared camera system so
for example
both the flood illuminator and the dot
projector
shine infrared light onto your face as
you can see in this video example and
that detail is extremely important for
enabling apple to put it underneath the
display so for example we see the
original face id sensor right here the
dot projector the flood illuminator and
everything else however apple made some
major changes to the design of the
iphone 13's notch as you can see right
here in ifixit's tear down one thing
they mentioned is that the notch is now
20 percent narrower on the 13 pro
compared to the 12 pro which you can see
basically right here look how much
narrow it is boom 13 right there and
that's the 12 much longer and the reason
they're able to do that is because apple
was able to merge the flood illuminator
and the dot projector into a single
module as you can see right here with
the new iphone 13 and that's the old
iphone 12 design so here's what i
believe apple is gonna do with the new
iphone 14 pro design they're going to
take that new dot projector and flood
illuminator single module and then
they're going to stick it under the
display right there because it works
using infrared light so behind the
display it's still going to be able to
shine those dots and the light onto your
face and make face id work which is very
very important so now if we go back to
the original face id system both the dot
projector and flood illuminator are now
going to be under the display on top of
that the speaker and microphone are gone
leaving just the camera the infrared
camera and the ambient light in
proximity sensors and that brings us to
the next very important detail if you
look at this image of the iphone 13
display panel you'll see some light
leaking behind this little area on the
display and guess what with the iphone
13 apple was able to put the ambient
light sensor completely underneath the
display so if you look at that the only
things remaining are the camera the
infrared camera and the proximity sensor
so with all that said i found this
little image on twitter showing the new
pill-shaped cutout with all the
components within it and some of them
are actually wrong because the ambient
light sensor is not within the whole
punch it's actually underneath the
display and i believe that the dot
projector is also going to be underneath
the display alongside with the flood
illuminator leaving only the front
camera the infrared camera because it's
gonna have a hard time reading it and
potentially the proximity sensor so yeah
that's how i think apple is going to
pull this off with this pill-shaped
cutout which i think makes a lot of
sense because no other android phone had
a pill shaped cutout centered like this
and i think this design looks really
good and i think this is going to be a
really good choice for apple to do and i
personally believe that apple is going
to stick to this design for the next
couple of years until they can finally
put all of it under the display which is
going to be very difficult especially
the selfie camera but we might see it in
a couple of years and of course the
regular iphone 14 models are gonna have
the same old notch from the iphone 13.
and finally to finish off this video
let's get into my predictions for the
design of the iphone 14 pro and renders
by shailesh helped me out with some
custom renders that are based on of
course the designs from john prosser and
ian's elbow with this awesome looking
iphone 4s style design with the circular
buttons and of course the cover glass
extending both ways and along with that
i also took some rumors from dylan dkt
who believes that apple is going to
remove the physical sim card with the
iphone 14 pro models at least and here
we go here is the reveal of the renders
and bam that's the iphone 14 pro or at
least what i believe is gonna look like
there's no sim card tray you have the
glass extending out the front and the
back except i personally believe that
the camera bump is still going to stick
out a little bit further than the glass
compared to having it flush like john
prosser believes and of course we have
the new pill shaped cutout with the
camera on the left side so that is my
design for the iphone 14 pro and if you
guys completely disagree with me go
ahead and comment down below but i think
this looks absolutely beautiful and i
would pay more than a thousand dollars
for this design if they upped the price
which i think they're gonna do so
hopefully you guys enjoy this and if you
did go ahead and click the circle above
to subscribe for more videos like this
one check out one of those two right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]